que confunden al cerebro del grillo
haciendo que se comporte de forma errática.
Cuando el grillo se acerca a un cuerpo de agua,
como esta piscina,
salta y se ahoga,
y el gusano se escape
del cadáver suicida.
Los grillos son muy espaciosos. ¿Quién lo hubiera imaginado?
La tenia y el gusano gordiano no están solos.
Son parte de toda una cabalgata
de parásitos que controlan la mente,
de los hongos, los virus y los gusanos e insectos y más
que todos se especializan en subvertir y reemplazar
las voluntades de sus anfitriones.
Ahora, me enteré de esta forma de vida
a través de "La vida a prueba" de David Attenborough
hace unos 20 años
y más tarde a través de un libro maravilloso llamado
"Parasite Rex" de mi amigo Carl Zimmer.
Y he estado escribiendo acerca de estas criaturas desde entonces.
Pocos temas en la biología me cautivan más.
Es como si los parásitos hubiesen trastornado mi propio cerebro.
Porque después de todo, ellos siempre son convincentes
y son deliciosamente macabros.
Cuando se escribe sobre los parásitos,
el léxico se incrementa con frases como
"devorado vivo" y "estalla de su cuerpo".
(Risas)
Pero hay más que eso.
Soy un escritor y los colegas escritores en la audiencia
sabrán que amamos las historias.
Los parásitos nos invitan a resistirnos a la atracción
de las historias obvias.
Su mundo es de giros en la trama
y de explicaciones inesperadas.
¿Por qué, por ejemplo,
esta oruga
empieza a golpear violentamente
cuando otro insecto se acerca a ella
y a esos capullos blancos que parece
que les está haciendo guardia?
¿Es tal vez la protección de sus hermanos?
No.
Esta oruga fue atacada
por una avispa parásita que puso huevos en su interior.
Los huevos eclosionaron y las jóvenes avispas
devoraron la oruga viva
antes de estallar fuera de su cuerpo.
¿Ven lo que quiero decir?
Ahora, la oruga no murió.
Algunas de las avispas parecían haberse quedado
y la controlan en defensa de sus hermanos
que se metamorfosean
en los adultos dentro de los capullos.
Esta oruga es un zombi guardaespaldas que se golpea la cabeza
en defensa de las crías
de la criatura que la mataron.
(Aplausos)
Tenemos mucho para repasar. Solo tengo 13 minutos. (Risas)
Ahora, algunos de Uds. probablemente
arañan desesperadamente un poco de consuelo
en la idea de que estas cosas son rarezas
del mundo natural, que son extrañezas,
y ese punto de vista es comprensible,
porque por su naturaleza, los parásitos son bastante pequeños
y pasan mucho de su tiempo
dentro de los cuerpos de otras cosas.
Son fáciles de pasar por alto,
pero eso no quiere decir que no sean importantes.
Hace unos años, un hombre llamado Kevin Lafferty
llevó a un grupo de científicos dentro de tres estuarios de California
y prácticamente pesaron y diseccionaron
y grabaron todo lo que pudieron encontrar
y lo que encontraron
fue parásitos en abundancia extrema.
Especialmente comunes fueron los trematodos,
pequeños gusanos que se especializan en castrar a sus anfitriones
como este desafortunado caracol.
Ahora, un único trematodo es pequeño, microscópico,
pero en conjunto pesaron tanto
como todos los peces en los estuarios
y tres a nueve veces más que todos los pájaros.
¿Y recuerdan el gusano gordiano que les mostré,
el grillo?
Un científico japonés llamado Takuya Sato
encontró que en una sola corriente,
estas cosas conducen tantos grillos
y langostas al agua
que los insectos ahogados
constituyen alrededor del 60 % de la dieta de la trucha local.
La manipulación no es una rareza.
Es una parte crítica y común
del mundo que nos rodea,
y los científicos han descubierto ahora
cientos de ejemplos de tales manipuladores,
y más emocionante, están empezando a entender
exactamente cómo estas criaturas controlan a sus huéspedes.
Este es uno de mis ejemplos favoritos.
Este es Ampulex compressa,
la avispa esmeralda cucaracha,
y es una verdad universalmente reconocida
que una cucaracha avispa esmeralda en posesión
de algunos huevos fertilizados
necesita a una cucaracha.
Cuando encuentra una,
la apuñala con un aguijón
que también es un órgano sensorial.
Este descubrimiento salió hace tres semanas.
Ella apuñala con un aguijón que es un órgano de los sentidos
equipado con pequeñas protuberancias sensoriales
que le permiten sentir la textura distintiva
del cerebro de una cucaracha.
Así como una persona enraíza ciegamente en una bolsa,
ella encuentra el cerebro, y le inyecta un veneno
en dos grupos muy específicos de neuronas.
Los científicos israelíes Frederic Libersat y Ram Gal
encontraron que el veneno es un arma química muy específica.
No mata a la cucaracha, ni la seda.
La cucaracha podría alejarse
o volar o correr si lo decidiera,
pero no lo hace,
debido a que el veneno inhibe su motivación para caminar
y solo eso.
La avispa básicamente desmarca la casilla de escape-del-peligro
en el sistema operativo de la cucaracha,
lo que le permite llevar a su víctima indefensa
de vuelta a su guarida por sus antenas
como una persona que pasea un perro.
Y una vez allí, pone un huevo en ella,
el huevo eclosiona, devorándola viva, estalla fuera del cuerpo,
ta ta ta, conocen el ejercicio.
(Risas) (Aplausos)
Ahora yo diría que, una vez picada,
la cucaracha no es una cucaracha más.
Es más bien una extensión de la avispa,
al igual que el grillo era una extensión del gusano gordiano.
Estos anfitriones no conseguirán sobrevivir o reproducirse.
Ellos tienen tanto control sobre su propio destino
como mi coche.
Una vez que los parásitos entran,
los anfitriones no tienen voz.
Ahora los seres humanos, por supuesto,
no son ajenos a la manipulación.
Tomamos drogas para cambiar la química de nuestro cerebro
y para cambiar nuestro estado de ánimo,
y ¿qué son los argumentos o la publicidad o las grandes ideas
si no un intento de influir en la mente de otra persona?
Pero nuestros intentos de hacer esto
son crudos y torpes en comparación
a la especificidad de grano fino de los parásitos.
Don Draper solo desea que él fuera tan elegante
y preciso como la avispa esmeralda cucaracha.
Ahora, creo que esto es parte de lo que hace a los parásitos
tan siniestros y tan convincentes.
Damos tanto valor a nuestro libre albedrío
y nuestra independencia
que la posibilidad de perder esas cualidades
por fuerzas invisibles
sustenta muchos de nuestros temores sociales más profundos.
Distopías orwellianas y cábalas sombrías
y supervillanos que controlan la mente,
estos son los tropos que llenan nuestra ficción más oscura,
pero en la naturaleza, ocurre todo el tiempo.
Lo que me lleva a una evidente
e inquietante pregunta:
¿Hay oscuros parásitos siniestros
influyendo en nuestro comportamiento
sin que sepamos de ellos,
además de la NSA?
Si hay alguno...
(Risas) (Aplausos)
Tengo un punto rojo en la frente, ¿cierto?
(Risas)
Si los hay, este es un buen candidato para ello.
Este es el Toxoplasma gondii, o Toxo, para abreviar,
porque la criatura terrorífica
siempre merece un apodo lindo.
Toxo infecta a los mamíferos,
a una amplia variedad de mamíferos,
pero solo puede reproducirse sexualmente en un gato.
Y los científicos como Joanne Webster han demostrado que
si Toxo entra en una rata o un ratón,
este se convierte en un misil roedor en busca de gatos.
Si la rata infectada huele el olor delicioso
de la orina de gato,
corre hacia la fuente del olor
en lugar de la dirección apropiada de alejarse.
El gato se come la rata. Toxo tiene relaciones sexuales.
Es el cuento clásico de la Comer, Rezar, Amar.
(Risas) (Aplausos)
Uds. son personas generosas, caritativas.
Hola, Elizabeth, me encantó tu charla.
¿Cómo controla el parásito a su huésped
de esta manera?
En realidad no lo sabemos.
Sabemos que Toxo libera una enzima
que produce dopamina, una sustancia involucrada
en la recompensa y la motivación.
Sabemos que se dirige a ciertas partes del cerebro de un roedor,
incluyendo aquellos involucrados en la excitación sexual.
Pero ¿cómo las piezas del rompecabezas encajan entre sí,
no está claro de momento.
Lo que está claro es que esta cosa
es una sola célula.
No tiene sistema nervioso.
No tiene consciencia.
Ni siquiera tiene un cuerpo.
Pero ¿está manipulando un mamífero?
Somos mamíferos.
Somos más inteligentes que una simple rata, seguro,
pero nuestros cerebros tienen la misma estructura básica,
los mismos tipos de células,
las mismas sustancias químicas que circulan en sus cuerpos
y los mismos parásitos.
Las estimaciones varían mucho, pero algunos datos sugieren
que una de cada tres personas en todo el mundo
tienen Toxo en sus cerebros.
Ahora normalmente, esto no conduce a ninguna enfermedad manifiesta.
El parásito se mantiene en un estado latente
durante un largo período.
Pero hay alguna evidencia de que las personas
que son portadoras tienen una puntuación ligeramente diferente
en cuestionarios de personalidad que las demás personas,
que tienen un riesgo ligeramente más alto de accidentes de tráfico,
y hay alguna evidencia de que las personas con esquizofrenia
son más propensas a ser infectadas.
Ahora, creo que esta evidencia aún no es concluyente,
e incluso entre Toxo investigadores,
las opiniones están divididas en cuanto a si el parásito
está influyendo verdaderamente nuestro comportamiento.
Pero dada la naturaleza generalizada de esas manipulaciones,
sería completamente inverosímil
que los seres humanos seamos la única especie
que no se vean afectados de forma similar.
Y creo que esta capacidad de trastornar
constantemente nuestra forma de pensar acerca del mundo
hace increíbles a los parásitos.
Constantemente nos invitan a soslayar al mundo natural
y a preguntar si los comportamientos que estamos viendo,
son simples y obvios
o desconcertantes y enigmáticos,
si no son el resultado de los individuos
actuando a través de su propia voluntad
pero debido a que se están sujetos
al control de algo más.
Y aunque esa idea puede ser inquietante
y aunque los hábitos de los parásitos pueden ser muy espantosos,
creo que la capacidad de sorprendernos
los hace tan maravillosos y tan carismáticos
como cualquier panda o mariposa o delfín.
Al final de "El Origen de las Especies",
Charles Darwin escribe acerca de la grandeza de la vida,
y de infinidad de formas muy bellas
y de lo más maravillosas
y me gusta pensar que podría fácilmente haber estado hablando
sobre una tenia que hace que al camarón sociable
o una avispa que se lleva a las cucarachas para pasear.
Pero tal vez, eso es solo una conversación de parásito.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)